>> Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome
C.E.O. Google Sundar Pichai.
[ Applause ]
>> Sundar: Thank you.
Thank you all for joining today.
It's great to be here.
It's an exciting moment for us.
We've evolved a long
way as a company.
I still remember looking
at our early data centers,
and I look at the scale
at which we are today,
which essentially represents
the way we have scaled our
infrastructure up.
We've also come a long way
as an enterprise company.
You know, I remember the
early days with Google search
appliance being our only
product and today we serve our
Enterprise customers
much more deeply.
We are at the beginning of what
is possible with the cloud,
which is why it's
special moment for us.
It feels like a special time,
the confluence of right people,
right technology
and the right time.
For us it got particularly
special in December because we
welcomed Diane Greene, a leader
with deep IT experience and the
pedigree of an entrepreneur.
She joined Google to run
all of Cloud and Apps,
and I can't imagine a
better person to do this.
She's already made many positive
changes and you'll hear about
all of them today.
When she started VMware, Diane
helped change the industry by
getting businesses start
off virtual machines.
Virtualization, the practice
of running several operating
systems at the same time,
on a single computer,
was an entirely new way of using
computers more efficiently.
It helped businesses
save a lot of money.
Today, we are at another
inflection point.
As you know, businesses are just
starting to adopt the concept of
a public cloud.
But what exists today is
largely a part of decades-old
technology, essentially virtual
machines to a scale server end
run, but in the future almost
everything will be done in the
cloud, because it simply is
a better way to do computing.
For years we have been investing
in scaling up our infrastructure
to do this.
Because the things we care
about as a business are the same
things many of you care about as
you're building your businesses.
Because of our investments,
we have scaled many products.
In fact, we have
over seven products,
each of which has a
billion users each.
And to put the scale in
perspective, in Gmail alone,
every single day we handle over
1.4 petabytes of information,
that's like 1400 Libraries
of Congress every single day.
We do this with
99.7% availability.
We do this across a private
network by having virtual
presence in every
corner of the world.
So we have scaled up our
infrastructure a lot.
And we primarily built it for
use by Google for our services
to serve our users.
But we are at a point where we
are opening it up so that every
business can build what's next.
And we want this to work
for all kinds of businesses,
whether you're a large business
like SnapChat or Spotify,
or a small business, or a
business of any size in between.
We don't think of this as
technology just for Silicon
Valley.
We want this to be technology
for every developer and every
business no matter
what size or location.
For example, in India, an
up-and-coming CGI animation
studio in Mumbai, Assemblage, it
used the Google Cloud Platform
to work on the recent animated
movie, "Norm of the North.".
It shows that you no longer need
to be a Google software engineer
to get access to
Google infrastructure.
And when we say
Google infrastructure,
we mean best
security, reliability,
analytics and computer research,
all of which you'll hear about
today.
As I said at the start,
this is a special moment.
We have set up with the right
people, the right technology,
and at the right time.
I know you want to get into more
details and we want to share
what's next, and
so to talk more,
I'm very happy to introduce
Diane Greene who needs no
introduction when it
comes to Enterprise.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
>> Diane: So welcome
and thank you, Sundar.
You know, one of the things
about I've discovered since
coming to Google is just the
excellence in experience brought
to bear on absolutely
everything everybody does.
I'm going to talk about that
in terms of our cloud today,
but I'm also just going to
mention this event and how
amazingly well
it's come together.
You know, yesterday those
beautiful windows on the bay
were garage doors, and there's
a kiosk out there with a giant
touch screen where you can
indicate your interest and it
will tell you different partners
that have relevant technologies.
Check it out.
I'm really looking forward
to scaling that up.
So welcome.
We've got several thousand
people here today,
here in San Francisco
on the wharf,
one of my favorite
places in the world,
and tens of thousands
more on live stream.
And we have -- and then at watch
parties we have people on six
different continents.
I also want to welcome the
190-plus press and analysts from
all over the world
that are here.
To all of you in the room
and everywhere, just welcome.
It's great to have you here.
[ Applause ]
Yeah.
Okay.
So I founded VMware
and, you know,
what we had there was just a
better way of doing things,
saved people lots
of time and money.
You know, I could go into any
business and it was so easy to
show the values, the benefits.
And what we have here at Google
Cloud is just so much more.
And as Sundar said, it's all
just a better way to do things.
This has kind of been a voyage
of discovery for me over the
last couple of years as I've
gotten to know everybody and
learn about all
the technologies.
You know, Google's
technical infrastructure,
just amazing inventions.
That's what allows Google to
power the biggest search engine
in the world.
And more recently taking our
machine learning technologies
and infusing them into our
products and more which you'll
hear about today.
Google's had no choice but
to do this with amazingly
sophisticated security.
But what's I think most exciting
to me is Google now's just so
all-in on what we can
do for the Enterprise.
All that we can bring and help
organizations of all sizes all
over the world.
I also want to add that Google
is strengthened by a pretty
broad portfolio
in the Enterprise.
You know, we've got Google maps.
We have chrome.
Android.
Google analytics just
launched last week.
And then our beyond productivity
office suite, Google Apps,
that all of Google runs on.
It's behind our culture.
We built it.
The collaboration and docks.
The video conferencing,
Hangouts, Drive, Gmail.
It's what lets us
be so communicative,
so transparent and
so collaborative.
Now, when I joined Google back
in December, as a Noogler,
you know, wearing one of those
propeller heads -- propeller
hats, I got -- on my very first
day I got to go visit Google's
biggest data center in Iowa, and
all of us that went were just
completely awestruck
by the lack of people,
mostly security guards,
the amazing security,
the HVAC systems,
and how green it was.
The incredible passion around
being energy efficient.
And that's kind of why I've
chosen pictures of data centers
as the backdrop for
most of my slides.
Our data centers and our
system's infrastructure are
invisible to our
customers and partners,
but they really underpin
everything we do.
So why -- you know, it's
been really exciting.
Customers -- we're seeing
real acceleration in customers
choosing us, and why
are they doing that?
Well, I think it could be put
into three main reasons: Better
value in terms of
price and performance.
Reduced risk in terms of
security, open source software.
And one of my favorite, the
access to the innovation.
I'll spend a few minutes going
to each one and I hope all of
you do a deep dive over the next
two days to learn more details
about this.
Our cloud is faster from
the BIS to the processors,
to the time it takes to bring
up some queued virtual machine.
A simple feature like snapshots
is one to two ordinates of
magnitude faster than the secure
copy which is the alternative.
And we're delivering on that
performance with the most
competitive price.
The efficiency with which we can
run our infrastructure lets us
offer this price performance
often 50% better, or better,
and our pricing is
customer friendly too.
We give you discounts
automatically the more you use.
We do things like provide
configurable virtual machines so
that you can configure
whatever machine you want,
be it 7 gigabytes, 6
cores, whatever you want.
We don't require it
to be a power of two,
which as you might imagine is
-- causes some pretty wasteful
overprovisioning, so better
value through a combination of
price and performance.
Oops.
Can you go back?
I -- I got confused.
Thank you.
Reduced risk.
Reduced risk, first
from security.
You know, something I've learned
since coming to Google is that
just an unbelievable tax that we
have on making all -- ensure all
our customers' data is secured.
You know, we've been hardened
over the years because we're
just in the crosshairs of all of
the best hackers in the world.
And so when you come
to Google Cloud,
you benefit from literally
thousands of people-years of
engineering that
we've put into this.
It's not just security, but it's
also the privacy and compliance
and the high bar we hold
ourselves to in terms of
protecting the privacy and
security of our customers.
But the other area of risk
reduction comes from our just
absolute commitment
to open source.
We open source -- we
take our innovations,
we put them in our products,
we open source them,
and then we provide an API, and
we're more than happy to compete
based on the quality
of our implementations.
We've open sourced Kubernetes,
our Container Engine for
managing server instances.
We've open sourced dataflow,
our batch and streaming data
pipeline.
It's currently in incubation as
an Apache Beam, on Apache Beam,
and we've open
sourced tensor flow.
That's our second generation
deep learning algorithms.
We're using them to power
services like image search,
or the smart reply in inbox.
And then of course,
once you open source,
you get a community, a vibrant
community where things can
improve more and more quickly.
The last reason,
access to innovation.
Our customers are already
benefiting from our approach.
We want to have
NoOps, automated IT.
It's based on our
serverless architecture.
Today we have App Engine,
BigQuery, and Container Engine,
they just work, without you ever
having to think about whether
you've got enough servers or
if things are working right.
And we're well on your way to
a full NoOps where you can just
write and run.
One of our best-known
customers is SnapChat.
They went from zero to more than
100 million users without even
formally hiring an ops team.
Tim Sehn, their VP of
engineering said, yeah,
it was just sort of
me and one other guy.
It's just work.
We've scaled up.
You see this in our
big data services.
There's really nothing close.
You type in the query, it's
instantly distributed across
thousands of cords and
magically it just happens.
What makes all this work is a
very dense network bandwidth,
we have widths in
between our clusters.
Our whole platform is designed
as an integrated architecture,
and without that, the kind of
highly distributed processing we
do is impossible.
One of the Spotify engineers
put it best in a tweet after we
announced they were using GCP.
"Finally I can tell the world
that BigQuery is the best thing
that's ever happened
to me." Now,
people don't say that unless
you're saving them an incredible
amount of time and effort.
So for us this access to
innovation is harvesting our R&D
investments in new productions
that everybody regardless of
your size, can use.
We'll have more to say
about innovation today.
You'll be hearing
about security,
our machine learning platform,
new approaches to operations for
hybrid cloud, and have since to
platform as a service plans and
our regional expansion plans.
And now I'll just take a few
minutes to talk about what's
ahead at a fairly high level.
You know, I've seen Google's
development accelerate over the
past 18 months.
I think it's nothing compared to
what we're going to be able to
do over the next two years.
But I'm going to highlight three
of the areas that we consider
particularly important:
Security, machine learning,
and the transition to the
next generation of cloud.
How we go to market.
How we help our
customers be successful.
First, security.
There's a lot more we
can do going forward.
We can take the tools that
Google's developed internally
and we can make them
available to our customers.
Machine learning.
Machine learning is pretty much
revolutionizing every industry.
It's really gotten to the
point where if your customer is
embracing machine learning,
it would be prudent for you to
embrace it too.
And you'll be able to expect
constant upgrades in our machine
learning and you'll be able to
expect more and more train data
in different verticals
supported over time.
Moving to cloud.
What we want to do here is make
it really nondisruptive for
everybody to move to our cloud,
to transition in a way that
saves them time and money and
actually uplevels what your
businesses can do.
It's really key to
our market strategy.
And just say that
in many, many ways,
cloud is so different from
selling Enterprise hardware and
software.
We're early in understanding
exactly how to sell well and
grow our customers.
Some of the basics are the same.
We're definitely setting up
programs to enable our partners,
providing training,
certification, solutions,
also for our customers,
and programs to ensure our
customers' success.
You know, one area that's really
getting some reinvention is
pricing models, you
know -- you know,
the cloud vendors do the --
should be the ones doing the
capacity planning, not the
customers with committing
long-term out.
That's the spirit of the cloud.
But what we're really seeing is
the technical expertise and the
advance planning required of us
to help our customers get ready
to move to the cloud, take
advantage of the cloud,
explore more optimal
ways to do things.
You know, we can see that we're
going to function as an applied
R&D team for our
customers, in effect.
And it's because of this that we
think we'll be able to give our
customers a step function
boost in their velocity.
And what do I mean by this?
What is this lift?
Well, I've learned almost
everything I know from racing
sailboats so I'm going to
use a boat metaphor here,
and with the exception
of planing, you know,
boats are kind of constrained
by how fast they can go by the
friction on the hull which is
proportional to the square root
of the water line length.
Not unlike -- this is not unlike
the friction existing between
computer architectures
and systems imposed on the
businesses, but I think there
it's an inverse function of the
ability to hire skilled
systems and operations people.
So we've all seen a revolution
over the last few years.
We saw it on San Francisco
bay in sailboats.
Hydrofoiling catamarans that can
go 55 miles an hour and making
its way to sailboats,
kite boards.
So we built the IT equivalent so
you don't have to spend the time
and money to do it yourself, and
it's at scale so we can serve
billions of users and
millions of businesses;
we can give you
this sort of lift,
this sort of force multiplier,
permanently accelerate your
progress and on
an ongoing basis.
So GCP is growing.
We're seeing potentially huge
growths in our core storage
services, our core compute
services and we're excited to
see the new innovations that
we're bringing out are just kind
of taking off.
Google Container Engine usage
has been doubling every 90 days,
growing faster than
virtual machines,
and we're expecting the
same from some of our newer
innovations that we'll
be announcing today.
We're serious about
this business.
Alphabet invested $9.9
billion in CAP X in 2015,
and that investment expands our
already-considerable ability to
provide cloud infrastructure
services to you today.
We're excited to make
our innovation engine,
our technology work for you,
for companies of every size,
and we really want to
make you a success.
Your success.
You know, it's so
exciting to us.
So it's terrific
to have you here.
Enjoy the conference, and
now it's just my incredible
privilege to invite up our next
speaker, our Alphabet chairman,
Eric Schmidt.
[ Applause ]
>> Eric: Thank you.
Thank you very much, Diane.
And thank you guys
for being here.
I was thinking about it; imagine
what an Internet operating
system really should be.
It should take
care of everything.
And it occurred to me that I've
been doing this for 45 years,
and that this notion of
increasing abstraction has been
in front of me my entire
career, literally.
So when I started, I was an IBM
360 hex assembler programmer.
Sorry.
And C was invented.
And I just thought it
was the neatest thing,
because programming
and assembly was hard,
and I kept arguing are the
computers fast enough, right?
Because I need a
really fast computer.
And eventually they convinced
me that C was fast enough.
I know this sounds archaic,
but the fact of the matter is,
the same has been true
for layer after layer,
and so this went from C and
C++ and then Java, of course,
which we announced -- I in fact
announced in 1994 next door at
Moscone, then into the Web
and then with infrastructure,
and it's also been
true of hardware,
and all the ways
everybody here knows here.
Soldering on chips, I literally
used to do this to many
computers to then the PC
architecture and now systems on
a chip.
The 1980s, we announced at Sun
the network is the computer.
And in 1997, I announced
the network computer, right?
So we've been working on this
for a very, very long time,
but each of these layers is
a new layer of abstraction,
and the whole idea is to
automate the tedious detail and
empower people, right?
That's really what it's about.
So along the way, Google
invents Google III.
Now, I'm often asked why
did we invent Google III,
and the answer is
because we had Google II,
and when it had an error, it
would say, grow up, horsy,
and then it would stop.
This was a problem.
And if you wanted
to delete files,
you had to make sure that the
mod file in the file security
handle changed without your
permission from 977 to 0,
and aside from that,
it was a great product.
So Google III was invented
roughly 2002, 2003,
internally at Google, all right,
in order to -- in order to sort
of build what you would think of
as the network operating system
that we needed.
And what's interesting
that this platform,
which we used obviously
incredibly successfully,
and at a time we were investing
four times more capital than the
sum of all of the other computer
companies in existence at the
time, just to sort of build out
the data structures and build
out these platforms, and so
what would happen if you came to
Google in a programmer
in sort of early 2000s,
you didn't have to think
about network segments,
denial service attacks, beat-off
IP addresses, scaling, SSL,
machine resources.
What happened was the machine
took care of it automatically
and you could
build Gmail, right?
Or you could build docs.
Or you could build the
next enhancement of search.
So in 2008, we announced App
Engine, and I figured weird up,
right?
I mean App Engine
is beautiful, right?
And many, many people
in this audience use it.
And what happened was App Engine
was like the APIs that went into
Google III.
All right.
so today, if you're
using App Engine,
you're using the same interfaces
that have been used internal at
Google.
I figured okay, we're done, it's
going to be hugely successful,
and along the way, here is what
we did: We built MapReduce,
you guys can use what
is called data proc,
which is sort of a more
sophisticated version.
We built Dremel, right?
You guys can use BigQuery, a
more sophisticated version.
We built something
internally called Colossus,
because we ran out of big names,
and you can -- you now know that
as Google Cloud Storage.
We built Stubby, not my
favorite product name.
You can use GRPC, also not
my favorite product name.
We built Bigtable;
you can use Bigtable.
Now that's a product
name that I like.
So the point is
it's really easy.
Just use -- just use
App Engine, right?
We're done.
Ah, and along the same way, we
got very interested in doing
sharing applications and
built this docs architecture,
and I remember sitting with the
executive in charge of docs,
and I said, "What's different?
What's different?
You got to show me what's
different." And he scratches
his head for awhile and
he said "sharing", and I,
in my typical stupid way said,
"Who cares about sharing?"
And he said, "Do you
share calendars?"
I said, "yeah." Well, sharing is
now what has driven Google docs,
apps, architectures,
all of that,
to 60% of the Fortune 500
are customers for this stuff.
We have more than 2 million
paying Enterprise customers.
It's a huge business for us,
and growing very dramatically,
so very, very proud of it.
But there was something
fundamentally wrong with my
conception in 2008 of
what we were doing,
which was it's not realistic
to expect people to go deNovo,
right, from an original
architecture into App Engine,
so we decided that we had to
change our strategy, 2009, 2010,
to basic -- you
know, it didn't work.
They didn't give the right
stepping time to the cloud.
It was too hard.
It didn't make any sense.
We decided to meet
you where you are,
as opposed to where we
think you should be.
Okay?
Makes sense.
First thing you've got to do
is you've got to do a virtual
machine, right?
And we do that.
And that becomes the initial
part of GCP as you know it
today, and we -- and I figured,
okay, well, we're done now.
We've done Internet OS.
Okay.
Well, that's not
quite true either.
You know, VM is sort
of pretty naked.
You've got to do an
awful lot of work.
Very difficult to sort of
control especially in a dynamic
environment.
We have resource competition.
How do you share files?
You have all these
issues around security.
In fact, oh, my God, you have to
go through the same list again
that you just went
through with Google III,
but now you have to
do it with the VM.
This is like a disaster.
It's like going back
in computer science.
So then we built containers, and
the core idea of a container is
that you can have a little
protected area where your code
runs inside the container, uses
all the resources and off you
go, and it works, right?
Today think Docker, right?
Docker on top, Linux
with extensions,
those extensions allowed the
containers to be properly
instantiated and turned on.
We had this funny product
called Borg, and I kept saying,
"What's the Borg?"
And everyone would
say, "That's the joke".
All right.
So a Borg was the manager
of all of these services.
So today this container
management and scheduling
management system that we've
built is the natural successor
to what we invented a
decade ago and it works,
and it works at a scale Google's
computer cluster is the largest
I think in the world, in
the universe, in the planet,
and everywhere else it combines.
It works at scale you've
never seen before.
It's mind-boggling
when I see it.
So then the problem was, now
we've got these containers,
how do we actually distribute
them and manage them,
and we invent Kubernetes,
and we open source it.
It's another name I'm a little
confused about but you'll get
it, I'm sure.
We finally got there, and the
reason I'm here is I want to say
to you right now,
45 years later,
20 years after -- 50 years
after the Internet was invented,
20 years after the network
computer was invented,
we've finally invented the
Internet operating system by
meeting you where
you are, right?
The path is now clear into this.
And what we've done is we
will now allow you to build an
abstraction layer at the cloud,
whatever you have to intersect
with.
And the reason Diane is here,
and doing a brilliant job,
is because now we have to
actually make that happen.
We've got the architecture.
We were joking about this.
The hard part is what
we have just done now.
The relatively easier part is
now getting the technical links
between it, but you've got to
get the abstraction right and
you've got to get the
scalability right,
and we have done
that, and I'm very,
very proud of this
as you can see.
Now, if you're not completely
with me -- let me give you a
simple example.
Take a 1960s car and try to
remember how to use the choke.
Okay?
Easy.
1970s cars, right?
I used to drive these things.
I still do.
You lost control on ice.
You had sudden braking.
No seat belt.
You could bump other cars
when parking the car, right?
You had to go to the Triple
A and get a paper map,
which was free, by the way.
You had to remember when
you had to service your car.
And you had to have
these big V6-V8 engines,
which of course they
sold you at a huge price.
The 2000s car tracks and
control, antilock, air bags,
rear bumper sensors,
navigation, service computer,
and turbo charging
to deal with scale.
It's exactly analogous, right?
Think about driving a car today.
You jump in a car;
it just works.
You don't have to
think about it.
It alerts you, so
forth and so on.
Go back to that 1960s car.
I'm not suggesting that the
platform that the car will drive
itself -- oh, yes, I am.
In fact in 2020, right?
[ Applause ]
The car drives itself, right?
So remember the choke, right?
Just remember the choke.
Now, the serious nerds
in the room here,
really liked the choke.
Nobody else did.
Okay?
That's the secret.
This cloud platform we're
building will abstract out all
of those examples
like the choke.
What it will do is it will give
you a platform that you can
really express.
Any times -- and the reason
it's so important to me,
is it's timed perfectly for
what's going to happen next.
And you're going to hear a
little bit about this in a
minute from a couple
of other people.
This platform is not the
end, it's the bottom.
And there's something above it.
And the thing that is above
it is machine learning.
Both narrow AI as it's
called as well as general AI.
And this is the
next transformation.
I just want to spend as much
time as I can on it because I
think it's so profound, and
it changes -- I'm basically a
programmer who sort of got
lucky, if you will, in Google.
Sorry, and the -- the
programming paradigm changes.
Instead of programming
a computer,
you teach a computer to learn
something and it does what you
want.
It's a fundamental
change in programming.
And we have just taken
the initial steps.
We -- the neatest example that
most people can understand about
machine learning are
involving vision.
We built a library, called
vision ML which we announced
which will be demoed today.
Vision ML does the
classification of photos.
All right.
It's great fun.
And if you get confused over
why this is so important,
use Google photos.
Spend a little bit of time
playing with Google photos.
It's not the fact that it
uploads it to the cloud,
it's not the fact, that
it does face recognition,
all of which used to be amazing;
it's the fact that it then
classifies all your photos
into what you're doing them in.
And how it does that
is beyond me, right?
I literally still
don't understand.
But perhaps the greatest example
is what happened in Korea a week
ago with AlphaGo.
AlphaGo as most of you probably
-- Go is the hardest game known.
It's incomputable in its
traditional -- and the team
invented neural network,
of which there are two,
a value network and
a policy network,
that could be used to
learn how to play the game.
So the most interesting thing
about AlphaGo is not that
they're brilliant -- brilliant
people or brilliant programmers,
but that they had to design,
as part of their software,
learning algorithms that were
tailored to the way the game
actually worked, and
that's the next layer.
It's the layer above.
And 20 years from now, people
will say remember the choke,
and then they'll say, yeah,
yeah, and in 2016, yeah, yeah,
we have all of those VMs
and all of that other stuff,
we don't think
about that anymore.
But somebody took care of it
and now all we're doing is doing
various forms of
learning, cognition,
and modification
improving of code.
So how do I
translate this today?
So I figured I would offer
sort of -- and put this in
perspective and finish up by
saying I think there's ten
things that you all
can do right now.
Obviously, thank
you all for coming.
And I'll read them now.
What's the list?
If I were right now working
on this right now today,
what would I do?
Well, I'd use Linux, I'd use
the Google Cloud and I'd use
Kubernetes, right, to write
applications that treat the
cloud the way I described.
In development, I would
use modern, portable,
scalable languages.
The one I like is obviously the
language Go, Python, Node.JS,
JavaScript -- Java, and then
use the Google App Engine.
If I had a clean sheet,
I would start there.
By the way, for
security, use two factor.
Let's try again.
For security, use two factor.
Right?
Don't use one factor.
And if you are sufficiently
paranoid, use three.
Okay?
Have fun, right?
[ Laughter ]
More factors are better.
But if you use our
infrastructure,
which essentially deals with the
distributed denial-of-service
attack, you will be protected
from this enormous explosion in
cyber issues that
everybody is dealing with.
Start with machine learning.
I mentioned Vision ML.
You're going to hear a whole
bunch more in just a minute.
We released a product
called TensorFlow,
which is the initial -- think
of it as nature's multiplication
platform for it, and it's the
foundation -- clear to me that
this is going to be the
foundation for this next layer
of programming, not just at
Google but everywhere else.
Google used SQL, right?
Used H base and H base is now
integrated in such a way that
you think you're using H base
but you're really getting the
power of our infrastructure.
So again, we've taken
something you use,
which is pretty good by the way,
SQL, been around for 50 years,
roughly, invented
in roughly 1970.
Works very well
for what it does.
Use it, but use it
in the right way.
And then you get all the
benefit of the architecture.
We've extracted that.
Try cause people.
Right?
See if you can get
the power of that,
and watch the space
for more from us.
What about data warehousing?
I think analytics should cost
less than other transactions,
right?
Try BigQuery, as Diane
mentioned, right?
There is no noncloud
equivalent of BigQuery.
Storage.
Start by deleting nothing
unless you're forced to, right?
It's so cheap.
I estimate that storage is
now a cent a gigabyte a month.
By the way, how did this happen?
The physicists have
been busy, right,
making discs that
are extraordinary.
Use Google Cloud
storage and those APIs.
Data processing.
As Diane mentioned, we have
something called dataflow.
Dataflow is the natural
successor to MapReduce, right?
Because it allows -- instead
of sort of back and forth,
which is the way to
think of MapReduce,
dataflow is more of
an updating process;
it keeps you constantly,
constantly on,
and constantly -- especially
for cloud services,
it's the only way, and then
finally I mentioned before use
GRPC.
Right.
Use a proper RPC mechanism and
do it in such a way that the
infrastructure supports it.
Why is it important
now to talk about this?
Because the industry
builds these platforms,
and another platform
and another platform,
and then have you this enormous
amount of code math that has to
be brought into it.
I'm now convinced that we've
figured out a way to meet you
where you are, right?
And we're investing as a
corporation thousands of people
enormous amounts of money over
the next few years to build the
infrastructure and the partners
to bring you wherever you are
into that model.
But there's another phenomena,
so that's getting to the cloud,
right?
Getting to -- You
can imagine the song,
get to the cloud
as fast as you can.
But there's another thing,
which is this layer above.
And I've become convinced that
there's a new architecture
emerging.
I'll describe it like this.
What happens -- I spent a lot of
time talking about innovation.
It's what I care a lot about,
and I talked to a lot of people
doing new things.
Those of you that are doing
startups and new models that are
not dealing with some of the
infrastructure and significant
issues that are the majority
of our focus are doing the
follow-on.
If you're building hardware,
you're building in a rapid
evaluation model.
You're iterating every week.
Didn't used to be
possible to do that.
When you're building
knowledge systems,
you're using crowd sourcing
to get the data that you need.
I use the Google
photos as an example.
And you're putting
into the Google Cloud,
using Google Analytics to do
some kind of very interesting
data analysis, and then
finally, in the next year,
you're going to use machine
learning to take that data and
do something that's better
than what the humans are doing.
Literally, you're going to take
human crowd source data and
you're going to
compute something new.
You're going to
discover something new.
And I'm convinced that little
model I described, rapid eval,
odd computing, using
Google Cloud Platform,
machine learning and crowd
sourcing the data will be the
basis and fundamentals of every
successful huge IPO win in five
years.
In the same sense that the
transition to apps five years
ago, which all of
us participated in,
created the modern corporations
of Uber, SnapChat, and others.
So it's not just that we
meet you where you are,
and it's not just that
you're taking the cloud,
the noncloud data and putting
it into the cloud in these
complicated ways which will make
things get a higher level of
traction, but there's
one more thing,
and that one more thing is the
invention of the use of crowd
sourcing and machine
intelligence and rapid
evaluation to create huge new
platforms, companies, IPOs,
wealth, and enormous things
going on in the future.
It's a great time
to be in the cloud.
It's a great time to be here.
Thank you, Diane,
for inviting me.
And I look forward to
seeing you all soon.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome Senior Vice President
Technical Infrastructure
Urs Holzle.
>> Urs: Thank you, Eric,
and good morning, everyone,
and welcome to NEXT
in San Francisco.
Since I started at
Google 17 years ago,
we built a whole lot
of infrastructure,
lots of data centers in 14
locations around the world,
and our goal when we started,
which is the same goal today,
was to build infrastructure
that makes it possible to build
amazing applications
and services.
So whether we were
indexing the entire Web,
or building a 3-D model of the
entire world down to the street
level, or predicting what users
are going to type next in a
search box, the product
ambitions have forced us to
rethink pretty much everything
in infrastructure; hardware,
software, and even the
way we work together.
And so this continues pressure
from product innovation,
and to stay ahead of that
product innovation has been
driving what's next for
cloud, namely the Google Cloud
Platform, GCP.
So today I'm going to talk
about three things: First GCP,
what it is now, how we built
it, and what's coming up.
Second, what's just over the
horizon, so what's coming next,
so that you can coordinate what
you're going to do next with us.
And then finally, some of the
companies that are building on
GCP, and I realize that
includes a lot of you,
so thank you for your business
and thank you for partnering
with us.
[ Applause ]
So before I talk about
that, about what's next,
I want to share quickly some
of the over 300 improvements we
made, just in the
last 12 months,
so you can see the pace
of our development.
Together we built a highly
differentiated platform that has
core infrastructure,
development tools,
and premium data services,
all built into it.
There's so many highlights,
and I can pick just a few,
but here we go.
Custom machines, Diane
already mentioned,
they let you choose any virtual
size machine and pay for just
what you need.
So there's no more
routine overprovisioning,
and the users who are using it,
our users are saving on average
19% off of their VM bill.
Dataproc is a fully-managed
Hadoop and Spark cluster,
lets you spin them up in 90
seconds, resize them up or down,
and you only pay by the minute.
And even better
dataflow, cloud dataflow,
lets you build pipelines,
you write the code once,
and you get both the streaming
and the batch analytics
pipeline, and you don't even
have to worry about building the
cluster.
Or about how to correctly handle
missing or late datapoints.
The system does that for you.
Archival storage has
traditionally meant trading
money for access time.
So you have to wait hours
to get your data back.
Well, no more.
We launched Nearline storage
that combines the price of tape
with nearly the speed of discs,
and it's using the same APIs
than regular storage, so you
don't have to change your
application after you've
archived your data.
So no more hours of waiting.
It's just seconds away.
VM startup times are down to
about 43 seconds on average and
falling further.
And even better, you can get
more than 100 VMs in our cloud
in about the time that it takes
you to get one VM in other
clouds.
That's the difference between
driving and flying -- or
actually it's the difference
between biking and flying.
High performance VM networking.
You can get up to two gigabytes
per second throughput to other
VMs or to storage on
every VM at Google.
So even data intensive
applications are never going to
be starved for data, and you get
that feature on Google in every
VM at no extra cost.
No other cloud offers such
high performance networking.
So you get networking.
As Diane mentioned, you can
connect directly to our network
in more locations than
in any other cloud,
and on that network, you get
network function as fully
managed services that are
easy-to-use, but very powerful.
So, for example, our load
balancer lets you balance across
any region in the world, and yet
it spins up from zero traffic to
million requests per
second instantly.
So in just the past year, we've
enhanced our platform with over
300 launches and that doesn't
even include what you're going
to hear about today.
And of course, we are still
the price performance leader.
Some of our customers see over
50% savings versus other clouds,
because we allow you to pay for
only what you need when you need
it.
And that makes it a lot easier
for you to work with us.
And it's not just something
that is nice to have.
If you have a job that only
runs for a few minutes,
but you have to pay for an hour,
or if you have a job that needs
20 gigabytes, but you
have to pay for 32,
or if you have a
bunch of unused VMs,
but you signed a contract
for them a few months ago,
so right there there's some
serious savings that you can get
when you're on GCP.
But cost isn't the only thing.
When you're thinking about
picking a cloud provider for the
next decade, innovation and
the quality of the underlying
infrastructure is
just as important.
In fact, if you're picking that
cloud provider for a decade,
innovation might actually
be the most important part,
so it's fine to
look at what's next.
Over the next five years, I
think we will see more change in
computing and in clouds than
we've seen in the last decade or
two.
Literally, an explosion
of innovation.
Now, why am I saying that?
I'm basing this prediction on a
well-known effect in biological
systems.
There, once the basic
capabilities come together and
start to function well,
they enable the evolution to
accelerate.
And we're entering a similarly
explosive period in cloud
computing innovation right now.
And as software gets woven into
our daily lives and into your
company, you all face the same
challenge that Google has faced
for many years, mainly how to
rapidly create more functional
applications using
these applications,
operate them at scale,
cheaply, efficiently, securely.
Or in short, how to create
better software faster.
And the user expectations on
that software are ratcheting up
rapidly, so today applications
are constantly being improved
with new features, and as users,
we're expecting the application
to tailor its behavior to
us the first time we use it.
And good apps delight us
by predicting what we want.
So for that to happen
in every application,
we have to have very easy-to-use
analytics and machine learning
frameworks that everyone can
embed in their applications.
So that's the first client.
We've got to do better
software faster.
Second, NoOps application
development will become
mainstream, because developers
spend way too much time
administering their setups.
So next it will be easy to run
even ambitious applications at
scale without knowing
all the details,
so that's the faster part
of better software faster.
To do that, we have to automate
most of the work provisioning
the running of services, and
with App Engine, dataflow,
Kubernetes, we're already
well on the way to that call.
Last but not least, you know,
Diane mentioned that security
has become more challenging
as attack surfaces continue to
multiply.
Very few companies
today are truly secure.
Very, very few.
And a significant portion of
security vulnerabilities are
created by process
vulnerabilities and by human
intervention.
So a lot of the key of getting
ahead of the security challenge
is to automate
security at scale.
Now, today, security is
often focused on securing the
perimeter, but next,
you know, tomorrow,
we need systems for security
and not band-aids or topical
antiseptics at the skin.
And so security is very deeply
embedded in GCP because we have
invested very heavily in
it, not just for clouds,
they're also for all
other Google products.
For example, we were the
first to offer two factor
authentication at scale.
The first to provide perfect
forward security in essence,
and elliptic curve cryptography.
Last December we announced data
loss prevention for Google Apps,
data rest and GCP is always
encrypted by default,
because we don't think you
should be forced to choose
between security and performance
or security and cost.
And we practice
security in depth.
Our team has discovered heartbleed to name just last
year or rowhammer exploits, and these investments are not slowing down.
And it's not just about security, but it's also about
privacy and compliance.
Every Google product needs to
meet rigorous standards and --
for privacy and compliance, and
our customers and our regulators
expect third party verification
of these standards.
And us, we regularly undergo
third party audits that verified
that all of our controls are
present in our data centers,
in our systems,
in our operations.
Now, with GCP, we're really
after building a different
cloud, and to
better explain this,
let me review where the
word "cloud" comes from.
The first wave of cloud started
about 20 years ago with the
emergence of co-located hosting.
Co-located hosting location gave
you the ability to rent space
rather than to build it, and
the status quo of cloud today
actually shares a lot with those
private inventors and co-located
data centers decades ago.
The components of today's
virtual data centers match the
physical building blocks
of hosted computing.
You have servers, you have
discs, you have load balancers,
you have CPUs, and so on, except
the virtual devices today,
and so what had been a purchase
order now today is an API call,
and that's a very profound
change that has benefited many,
many customers.
But the basic building blocks of
those virtual data centers have
not changed yet, and it's still
extraordinarily complex to
orchestrate these building
blocks together at scale,
because this model forces
developers to still think much
of their time thinking about
other things other than making
their application great.
So do we have enough servers?
Are they all patched?
Did we prepurchase too
much capacity, right?
In the virtualized data center
world, this never gets easier.
And actually it's a bit crazy
that today's cloud is based on a
physical model with all the
limitations that was created 20
years ago, right?
It's kind of like the virtual
data center of today still has a
manual choke, right?
Kind of doesn't make sense.
And but, you know, I'm a little
bit embarrassed to admit that
actually we used to run
Google exactly that way,
the way I just described.
Until about ten years ago, our
world internally looked pretty
much like that.
But then we realized that we
couldn't really keep up with the
rate of change
that Google needed,
and so we switched
to a new model,
distracts away all of those
servers and is based on
containers, not machines.
So today we use a third
wave cloud, if you want,
the combination of automated
services and scalable data,
and we call this
approach "serverless",
because you care about your
code not -- on your application,
not your servers.
So while the industry is just
starting to talk about that,
serverless architecture is very
deeply embedded in all of GCP.
So in App Engine, for example,
App Engine lets you run code
snippets, large or small,
without specifying where they
run, and your application
scales all the way down to zero,
so if nobody is using your
application, you don't pay.
In GKE, you can run containers
without specifying the machines
they run on.
In dataproc, you can create
Hadoop clusters without actually
worrying about the cluster.
In dataflow embedder, you don't
even need to worry about the
cluster.
You don't even need to
package container images.
You just give us your
code and it runs.
So the code just runs,
and as a developer,
you never manage servers.
So that's the true meaning
of third wave cloud.
And GCP has the most integrated
approach to that serverless
architecture, so you can start
taking advantage of it without
throwing away your
existing code.
So now, to give you
the details about that,
it's my pleasure to introduce
Brian Stevens who heads all of
our product management.
Welcome, Brian.
[ Music ]
>> Brian: Thanks, Urs.
So as Urs was saying, this next
generation of cloud is already
happening.
It's already bringing out
services that are freeing users
from thinking about virtual
machines and storage and blocks
on discs.
So instead they're starting
to focus more on their
applications, their users
and then just building their
business.
And we have many customers that
are actually coming to GCP today
for exactly that reason.
So instead of filling
with infrastructure,
they're using full zerop
services like App Engine and
BigQuery, so I want to get
started really quickly and
introduce you to one
of them right now.
>> Video: We wanted to make this
marketing campaign for Coca-Cola
something that every single
person in this world,
no matter who you are, could
participate in the World Cup
experience.
Submit your photo, you could
be on the pitch at the opening
ceremony of the World Cup.
>> We're talking about 3 million
and a half images from over 200
countries, different
formats, different users,
different sources.
>> Fans could actually find
their photos to know, okay,
I was here on the flag in
the opening of the World Cup.
>> It was a gigantic scale.
The agency that was creating the
photomosaic printed in fabric,
we recreated the
equivalent digitally.
We did not have time to set up
an infrastructure and set up the
servers and configure
the machines.
By using the Google
Cloud Platform,
we sent straight into
building the top of it.
Without that my first
deliverable would be impossible.
>> You have to predict what
the loads are going to be.
There's a lot of uncertainty.
When you look at a cloud
provider like Google,
the opportunity there
is for autoscaling.
You don't have to worry
about disaster recovery,
you don't have to
worry about backup,
because it's provided
to you as a service.
>> We wanted to send every one
that had an image in that flag a
notification the very moment the
flag was opened physically in
the field.
We had a lot of people
doing that simultaneously.
They're not taking
turns to use it,
so we were monitoring the
transmission on TV and waiting.
I remember clearly seeing the
spikes and just hoping please,
please, scale up,
scale up, and it did.
>> Fundamentally it gets down
to one thing and it's one word;
it's trust.
The same infrastructure that
powers the Google search engine
and search experience is
what's powering the cloud that
Coca-Cola is running on.
>> The biggest digital
marketing initiative.
>> To participate is like a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity.
[ Applause ]
>> So we're really lucky today
because we have the C.T.O.
of Coca-Cola here Alan Boehme.
[ Music ]
So Alan, I wanted to
ask you a few questions.
So first of all, like how did
you actually decide to get
started with Google
Cloud Platform?
>> When you're
working for Coca-Cola,
which is one of the largest
brands in the world,
almost 2 billion servings a
day, and you have Google that is
serving up over 3.5
billion searches a day,
it's all about scale.
And when you start talking about
putting something on the world
stage for FIFA that's seen
in 207 different countries,
every place in the
world is participating,
you need to partner with
somebody that really understands
scale, understands reliability.
We can't miss,
because if we miss,
it's a miss for
the entire world.
>> So the video is
really compelling, right?
You can get inspired by that.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about some of the other
ways that you're using GCP?
>> So we've been advancing with
GCP and with Google in general
for awhile now.
We're moving into an
analytics platform.
We're taking advantage of many
of the things that we heard
earlier.
We're moving forward
with machine learning.
We're real excited about all the
new activities that are going on
and the points of opportunity
that are made available to us.
In addition, we have created
a relationship with Google.
We've worked on security.
We're a very big believer in
the software to find perimeter.
Google has announced
their BeyondCorp strategy.
We're partnering at a different
level that we have with many
other companies in the past,
and it's to the benefit of us,
our consumers and to everyone.
>> So and from your team inside,
how is just using Cloud changed
from how they do things
from five years ago?
>> We're 130-year-old company.
We're 130-year-old company.
We have this culture in
IT that's been going on,
not going to say 130 years,
but certainly for many,
many generations, and its hard.
Working with Google, working
with Google team and the
platform is changing
the culture,
changing the skill
sets that are required,
and it's going to help make us
competitive going forward in the
next century.
>> Awesome.
Well, thanks for joining us.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Brian: So our data center,
our cloud is this really dynamic
environment.
Things are always changing.
We're constantly
improving hardware.
We're improving software.
And we even change things
how we do operationally,
and you can't just shut down
the cloud when you're actually
changing out servers and
upgrading and working on
infrastructure.
So we had to support the rate
of innovation that we need.
We had to design agility
and change into both our
architecture as well as our
operation proceedures from the
beginning.
And that's really the reason
why we're perhaps the only
hyperscale cloud that actually
depends on live migration.
And so that really allows us to
upgrade our infrastructure and
our software stack and the
applications don't even know
about it, because not all
applications are built in this
microservice architecture where
they can -- pieces can be taken
down.
So now whether if we're
upgrading that server,
if we're applying a patch
to a underlying host to us,
we can even actually service the
power infrastructure underneath
the whole cluster because we
have the spare capacity to live
migrate the VMs, so applications
don't notice when they're
running on GCP.
And at the same time, GCP is
actually the greenest cloud in
operation today.
So today in the
average data center,
about 40% of all power actually
goes for things other than
servers.
Right?
And so that's just waste.
And by comparison,
in our data centers,
only about 10% of power goes for
anything other than that server.
So you think about how
little overhead that is.
And we actually continue
to get a lot better,
so we now get three times the
amount of compute capacity out
of the same amount of power
as we did just five years ago.
So as Diane was saying, to
join her and Urs on that trip,
a very emotional experience.
It was definitely the tenure
of my -- of my time here.
And you really did expect to see
these football field size rooms
full of servers, and
it was just that.
It was really daunting, but it
was everything else that was
around the server that
was really compelling.
It was the power infrastructure.
We were climbing on top of,
you know, water coolers,
and just the lights
out management.
Retinal eye scan like to get
inside the data center is really
impressive.
But one of the aha moments to
me was -- and I think, you know,
everybody else at Google
takes this for granted,
is when you leave this amazing
data center and you walk outside
and the next one is
already being built,
and you would think that
once you've, you know,
delivered perfection you
would just keep cloning it,
but the next data center looked
remarkably different than the
one that you just left.
The size of the floors, the
height of the ceilings were
different, they were
going to four stories,
and that just shows you the rate
of innovation that's happening
in this area today.
So if you didn't believe
that computing would become a
utility, one visit to Iowa,
and it becomes really obvious.
So we can't bring
you all to Iowa,
but we actually prepared a
virtual reality tour for you
today, so here is Greg Wilson,
he leads our developer app GCP
team.
[ Music ]
>> Greg: Good morning.
Thanks, Brian.
So, as Brian was saying,
we went to a data center.
A few months ago we -- our team
got together to figure out where
we wanted to go for a team
retreat and we had a few
options.
We could go to
Whistler, Lake Tahoe,
or the middle of Oregon
to a Google Data Center,
and of course you
know the one we chose.
That was absolutely
a no-brainer.
So we -- I mean you've heard
everyone talk about how much
they were blown away by it,
and we had the same experience,
and it was even in
ways we didn't imagine.
And because we're developer
advocates, you know,
our instant instinct is to
share that with everybody.
It's like how in the world can
we get people in here short of
doing public tours?
They wouldn't let us do that.
Sorry.
So what we put together is
something a little new -- if you
could switch to -- it's
already on the tablet.
So I'm going to be showing 4K
video using conference Wi-Fi
from a tablet.
What could go wrong?
[ Laughter ]
So this video is a
little different.
I'm just going to show you
a couple of minutes of it.
I'll show you how to
get to the rest of it.
This is a 360video, and
I'm doing this on a tablet,
so as I turn the tablet -- and
you can do this with any of your
devices.
As I turn the tablet,
you see the view turning.
And I'm really trying to be
steady here so you don't get
nauseated.
And it's not just 360
circular; it's spherical.
So you can look up, look down.
And not playing the sound
for obvious reasons,
but we have closed captioning
in fourteen languages.
By the way, that's Chris
from the security team.
He -- he kept an eye
on us the whole time,
and you'll see that in
all the other scenes.
I want to fast forward and just
show you another quick glimpse,
and then I'll tell you how
you can go see it on your own.
So this is the cooling
room in the data center.
And they tell you all
about what's going on here.
And of course, we want to
make sure that we have proper
security.
There he is.
Right over there.
All right.
So, again, I'm not
going to -- anyway,
this is not the most ideal
way to experience the video.
You can switch
back to the slides.
Thank you.
So to view this video, you go
on your browser -- using Chrome
browser on your desktop, you can
use your mouse to look around.
You can view it on mobile
device using the YouTube player,
and you can do what I was just
doing, move it around like this,
or swipe to look left,
right, up and down.
The most immersive way to do
it, the coolest way to do it,
is with Google Cardboard.
So you put the
device in Cardboard.
You put YouTube player
in Cardboard mode,
and it's like you're there.
As close as we
can get you there.
So you'll all receive a Google
Cardboard tonight at the party.
We've got one for
every one of you.
We also have a theater out in
the playground area that plays
this on an 8-foot screen.
It's a circular screen and
you get to hear the whole
soundtrack.
You can meet Sandeep
who stars in the video.
He's on our team.
So I encourage you to come over
to the program look at that and
some of our other experiences
and I hope you guys enjoy it.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Brian: Thanks, Greg.
So when you run on Google, your
traffic runs on the world's
largest network backbone, right,
with direct connections to
thousands of ISPs in
nearly every country.
And as Urs was saying earlier,
we have 77 piering points that
are in all the major metros,
and those are really important
because that's actually where we
integrate directly piering with
our network partners and most
recently our CDM partners and
our largest customers.
So speaking of that
global network,
we're actually going to continue
building out regional support
for a cloud platform, and
we actually just announced
yesterday that we're adding two
new regions in Tokyo and Oregon.
So Greg just got
to go see Oregon.
[ Applause ]
And that's really important,
but we're not done, right?
Once we get the model
down, as we are with Tokyo,
then we can go even faster.
So we're actually going to
be adding ten more locations
through the end of 2017.
So on a hybrid called mini,
users are actually using more
than one cloud, right, and that
might be because look at some of
the services that
we're talking about.
There's different services that
aren't available on all clouds,
so they're using multiple
services that might be for --
for risk or cost or other
things, or even archival.
But the -- but the challenge
of that is is that all the
providers, including On
Premise, Private Cloud,
we all build our own tools and
kind of put you in this little
operational silo, right?
And so we think that's,
you know, a real problem,
and it just makes it harder
for users to consume multiple
clouds.
So Google Stackdriver is a
service for monitoring, logging,
visualizing, and alerting,
across cloud services,
across your resources,
across your applications.
And so we wanted to get you
out of that sort of operational
silo.
So one of the things that we did
is we just announced beta for
Google Stackdriver today,
and now it will actually be
available and it will support
GCP as well as AWS with private
cloud coming.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
So gives you that single pane
of glass that you would expect
where you can, you know, issues
are sort of propagated really
quickly.
You can find them, visualize
them, and resolve them.
Another challenge with -- with
hybrid cloud is the applications
are just really married into
the underlying infrastructure.
Whether it's the dependencies
they have on different operating
systems at different
release levels,
maybe they're building inside of
virtual machines and their app's
trapped inside of VMDK or it's
up on a QEM UKVM image or it's
on Amazon with AMI, so
applications really aren't that
lightweight and portable, and
that's a really powerful thing
that Eric was saying earlier
about containers and namely
Docker.
It's really for the first
time giving this industry this
portability at the
application level.
And so when you
think about that,
think about what that means
for hybrid cloud consumption,
because now we're actually
helping enterprises consume
containers and they're
getting more agile On Premise,
at the same time they're
actually able to use support
hybrid clouds, and so moreover
we really realize from our
experience back in the Borg
that it's not just about the
containerization, it's really
about the management of
thousands of containers and how
do you deal with rollout of new
applications, and that was
what Kubernetes was all about.
Let's open source the
best of what we know,
not just so that
hackers can have it,
so that large enterprises can
consume orchestration at scale,
and by -- by default be able
to support public cloud.
So let me introduce now Greg,
and Greg is actually going to
take us through everything
that we've been doing with both
Google Stackdriver as
well as with containers.
[ Music ]
>> Greg: Thanks a lot, Brian.
I'm really happy to be here
to show you today the next
generation of monitoring and
logging with Google Stackdriver.
Now, I cannot talk and
type at the same time,
so I'm very grateful to have
Dan Belcher out on stage here to
help me with this demo.
Now, you heard a lot about
openness being a critical piece
of everything we do at Google,
and it's really no different
than monitoring and logging.
So to see that in action, let's
take a look at this Stackdriver
screen.
I've got a Stackdriver
environment,
and the first thing you'll
notice at the top is I'm
monitoring multiple
GCP projects.
That's a new capability,
and it's really important,
because whether you're an
individual developer or you're
an operational specialist,
you want to have a complete
visibility across everything
that's going in your
organization.
You don't want your monitoring
silo'd into different parts of
your organization.
Down at the bottom, you'll
notice something that you
probably might not
have expected to see,
and that is I have a
set of AWS accounts,
Stackdriver's design to
let you do monitoring,
logging and alerting across
both Google Cloud and AWS.
One pane of glass,
multiple clouds.
So Dan is going to switch us
over to the main Stackdriver
console.
For this application
we're running here,
this is a multi-cloud
application.
I've got NGINX, and I'm sending
traffic to both AWS and GCP.
So if you look
down at the bottom,
you'll see some request graphs,
and you'll notice that we're
currently sending about 90% of
the traffic to AWS and about 10%
to Google.
Now, I may be biased, but
that seems backwards to me.
So I'm going to have Dan here
run a script in the background
that switches that and starts
redistricting the traffic onto
GCP.
Now, that takes a little
bit of time to propagate,
but that's okay, because it
gives me a few minutes to show
you some other new
features of Stackdriver.
The first thing I want to show
you is intelligent defaults.
Dan is drilled into a page
specifically on our ELB
monitoring, and you'll notice
I get a dashboard that's
automatically showing me the
right events and metrics.
It's not showing the useless
things like CPU load or memory
load.
It's showing me application
latency, 200 response codes.
Same thing if I switch
over to the NGINX piece.
I'm getting a set of charts
that are giving me intelligent
defaults.
Now, the key here is
what you're not seeing.
Dan didn't have to go and tell
Stackdriver that ELB is a load
balancer, and therefore
these are the right metrics.
He didn't have to
tell it what NGINX is.
Stackdriver has intelligent
defaults for a huge range of
both commercial and
open source libraries,
so you can just build your
application and you get the
right dashboarding, the right
metrics right out of the box.
You can also create
custom dashboards.
In this case, maybe I'm
an operational specialist,
and I don't want to drill down
into the specifics of a service.
I want to aggregate all of my
network traffic across all my
services into one pane of glass.
And of course, we can -- you can
customize the user interface,
the look and feel.
Now, the next thing we want to
go to is what happens when there
is a problem?
Now, dashboards aren't enough.
I need realtime information.
I want to see what's
happening right this second.
So we're going to
switch to logging,
and that's another important
capability of Stackdriver.
Dan is going to go ahead and hit
the play button and we're going
to get playing in realtime
logging information,
so as errors are logged
in either AWS or GCP,
I'm getting a view
here of all of those.
And in fact, there are a couple
of errors coming because we're
doing the fail over from one
cloud provider to another.
You can also create metrics
and alerts based on logs,
so you can make sure that you
get an alert when certain error
messages appear in
your log systems.
But we're actually going to
leave that sort of for another
day.
I'm not going to actually
create one of those right now.
If I go back to the
main monitoring console,
we can see that -- here
we go, as the graph loads,
we can see in fact the requests
on the AWS side are dropping,
the requests on the
GCP side are coming up.
I've got no alerts.
No errors other
than that happening.
Everything is fine.
So today Stackdriver's
available in beta.
It's a great monitoring solution
whether you're using AWS,
whether you're using GCP
or whether you're using a
combination.
If you think about what it would
normally take to do what I just
showed you, we'd have been
running through multiple
different tools for
logging and monitoring.
We would have one tool for
each of our cloud providers.
All to do that.
Stackdriver gives me
metrics, logs, dashboards,
up-time monitoring
all in one system.
It also includes tracing,
error reporting, debugging.
We're going to have more
sessions on that throughout the
conference.
I encourage you to go to those.
So that's monitoring
and logging.
Now, let's turn to the business
of deploying and running
applications.
You've heard a lot about the
role of containers in this whole
notion of a wave 3 cloud
application and how we know from
our experience at Google
that they really are a key to
managing systems at scale.
This idea of moving from a world
of managing individual servers
to managing applications
and services.
That's why we started
the Kubernetes project.
That's also why we are inviting
the industry to be part of it,
because for containers to take
on the real prominence that we
think they're capable of, it
will take the whole industry to
come together to
make that happen.
It's also why hybrid cloud was
a fundamental design point from
Kubernetes from the beginning to
allow you to deploy containers
on one cloud or another, with
virtualization, with Bare Metal,
On Prem, so Ray is
going to come up here,
and we're going to give
you a demo of containers,
and we're going to start with a
demo of Container Engine which
is our fully hosted
Kubernetes environment.
So Kubernetes is designed
to be declarative.
You don't deploy applications
with this complex mess of
scripting code that
runs at deployment time,
and God help you if it fails and
you have to debug a partially
deployed application.
Kubernetes is
entirely descriptive,
so Ray's going to open up
the file that describes this
particular application.
I'm not going to drill
into the whole thing,
but you'll notice we're saying
that we need ten instances of a
particular back end server,
we're defining what ports we
need are open, and again what is
relevant here is what you don't
see.
I don't see here
N 1 standard 8s,
or machine sizes or memory
sizes or disc sizes.
Kubernetes will just find the
right capacity in my cluster and
it will schedule
this job wherever.
As a programmer, I just operate
at the level of applications and
services, not at a bunch of
infrastructure that I really
don't actually care
that much about.
So great, he's going to exit out
of his editor and we're going to
do a deployment, so he's going
to use the Kubernetes command
line to deploy this
application into GKE.
Now usually at an
event like this,
I would plead with you to not
get your phone out and not do
anything on the Wi-Fi, but we're
going to do a little running
with scissors here.
I'd like you to actually send
some load to this application
for us.
There's a URL there
on the screen.
HCR.KAS.IO.
Really.
No, I mean that, like
please help me out,
get your phones out, go
navigate to the site.
While people do that -- and
start clicking that button.
While you do that, we're going
to see the load go up on this
application on the chart there.
Okay.
I give you guys an A for effort.
But nobody at Google would call
150 queries per second Internet
scale.
Luckily, that's what load
testers are invented for,
to give us sort of
a helping hand here.
So Ray's going to kick off a
load tester that's going to send
about 20,000 requests per
second to this service.
And you'll see it start
ramping up, and sure enough,
that's great, no problems.
Now, if I did this
demo 18 months ago,
this would have been, you know,
considered an amazing thing,
like who has the ability to
build services that run at that
scale?
And now it's my
hello world demo.
But what happens when you want
to update your application?
Now, you all know
the right answer.
You do a staged update.
You do the 1%, 5%, 10%, you
monitor it very closely.
You hope you don't
have to roll back,
but in reality that's a hard
thing to do while you're serving
20,000 requests per second.
Kubernetes has built in the
ability to do automated scalable
rollouts so it will just -- it
will slowly roll out updated
versions of your
application over time.
Now, to do this right, I should
make this take, you know,
a day or two.
We're going to -- we're going
to go ahead and condense this,
so he's going to do a
rolling update command,
and we're going to tell it to
really push this thing as fast
as possible.
So what you're going to see is
down there on the bottom of the
chart, there's the
version numbers,
and you're seeing as Kubernetes
is one by one replacing one
instance of our application
with the updated version,
so the green slowly shifts to
-- the blue shifts to green.
If we keep clicking the button,
eventually you'll see -- you'll
experience the new version of
the application and the button
will change color.
So there we are under a load
of 20,000 queries per second.
We're doing a live rolling
update of the application,
and you'll notice what the
QPS really just stays very,
very steady at about
20,000 requests per second.
Our users never even
noticed we did an update.
So that's -- go ahead, yes.
[ Applause ]
So that's our application
running on GKE.
But we talked about hybrid cloud
as being a key design goal,
and one of the challenges of
hybrid is how do I bridge my On
Premise infrastructure
deployments and my new cloud
infrastructure deployments?
They have different
tools, different language,
different ways of working.
Kubernetes can help with that.
Ray is going to switch
over to another tab here,
and this tab has the same
SDKs, same tools installed,
but instead of being
pointed at a GKE cluster,
it's being pointed at a cluster
right over here on the right
part of the stage.
That server rack over there.
Our friends at Intel have
graciously loaned us a rack of
servers.
Those aren't even
running virtualization.
Those are bare metal servers
with Kubernetes running on them.
They use the latest generation
Intel Z on processors.
Kubernetes is totally
optimized for that.
So now he's going to
use that same command,
and now the application is being
deployed over there on to our
rack.
Now if you go and see --
look at the load graph,
you will see that we've put a
load balancer in front of GKE
and in front of our On
Premise infrastructure.
And you'll see seamlessly our
application is being deployed.
The instances, now there's
20 versions of my application
running.
We're seamlessly
splitting the traffic,
both serving about 20,000 QPS.
So there you go.
Five minutes.
We took an application.
We deployed it.
We did a rolling update to it.
We bridged that application to
our On Prem infrastructure all
without having to deal with
the differences between the two
environments.
Thanks, Ray, that
was a great demo.
[ Applause ]
>> You heard from a few of our
customers and we have more on
the way.
But while we're getting
things set up on stage,
we want to watch this short
video of what our customers are
doing on GCP.
>> Cloud's fascinating, because
really what it's done is it's
completely changed the
speed of innovation.
>> From hosting websites Compute
Engines to data prediction it
offers the flexibility
that companies need now.
It's what makes Cloud and
Google Cloud Platform very,
very important to
our businesses.
>> I grew up just absolutely
loving visual effects.
When we started Atomic Fiction,
one of the most challenging
parts of doing visual
effects is rendering.
It takes an immense amount
of computing horsepower using
Google Cloud Platform, we have
massive infrastructure off site
when we need it and then
nothing when we don't.
It helped us put the resources
on the artist and making sure
that every penny that our client
spent made it up on the viewing
screen.
>> Khan Academy's mission is a
free world class education for
anyone, anywhere.
Google Cloud Platform allows
us to stay focused on learner
outcomes because our
infrastructure has become this
invisible layer that we don't
have to worry about anymore.
>> Keeping track of that much
data for millions of students
every day is a
challenging problem.
And storing all that data and
being able to quickly act on it
and look at it is really
core to our mission.
>> The name Pocket Gems really
speaks to what we do which is
make beautiful things
for your mobile device.
>> For War Dragons in minutes or
hours you might have hundreds of
thousands on players
playing your game.
If you don't have the
server infrastructure,
your servers are just
going to explode.
Google Cloud Platform allows
us to be able to scale
automatically.
You don't have to
think about that.
Your backend just works,
it's almost magical.
>> Payments are the connective
tissue of economies and that
really resonates with
Nomonin Anywhere.
We are providing payments in
the massive underserved markets.
>> Hosting our application on
Google Cloud Platform gives us a
much higher reliability than
we could have gotten hosting
ourselves.
>> We're really able to move the
needle and make those payments
available and
affordable everywhere.
>> The mission at Spotify
is really about being a great
musical companion and then
making it more personal.
>> Moving to Google's Cloud
Platform enabled us to take use
of the skill that
Google can provide.
>> The reality is, it's quite
hard to build great data centers
and that was really the driver
in to Google's Cloud Platform.
The less time that we can
spend solving problems that are
already solved, the more time
and energy we can spend on
turning our data into value.
>> We wanted to make this
marketing campaign for Coca-Cola
something that every single
person could participate.
Submit your photo, you can be on
the flag and the opening of the
World Cup.
>> It was a gigantic scale.
We did not have time to set up
an infrastructure and set up the
servers.
By using Google Cloud Platform,
we went straight into building
the top of it.
>> Fundamentally it gets
down to one word, it's trust.
The same infrastructure that
powers the Google search engine
is what's powering the cloud
that Coca-Cola is running on.
[ Music ]
>> Well, I hope you enjoyed
that little sneak peek.
Sorry to cut it off, but
we got to get back inside.
The CTO and SVP of Walt Disney
Company is on stage right now.
>> Whoa!
>> So, we're really lucky
to have Mike White here.
He's the CTO of
Disney Interactive.
[ Applause ]
Great video.
Definitely an
innovation company.
So how do you actually think of
the role of technology and how
it applies at creating
even more innovation.
>> Yeah, it's ironic being here
where technology is very front
forward.
As we look at our jobs and
when Disney is at its best,
technology is always
in service in the story.
It's always been a key aspect
to the Walt Disney Company's
approach to story telling.
And over 100 --
almost 100 years,
we have had innovators
that have invented,
reinvented industry after
industry from travel to
entertainment.
So if it's our films, if it's
our parks, if it's our games,
and if it's our products,
technology is always in service
of the story.
It's always the scaffolding but
the story telling comes first.
And that's what's
really paramount to us.
And as technology becomes more
and more prevalent to everyone,
it also becomes more powerful,
it's super important that we
have those tools and provide
those tools to our story tellers
such that they can provide
the magic to our guests.
>> So how does the
cloud fit into that?
How does Google actually
help you with all of that?
>> So, yeah, a couple of
things to provide context.
So I look after consumer
products and interactive media.
We are the part that lives with
the guests in their day-to-day
lives.
So we have 1.6 million products.
We have a fabulous mobile games
team that publishes tons of
games that people play millions
and millions of hours on.
We also look at
our Disney stores.
We have the largest with
the kids -- largest kid book
publisher.
And when you look
at our landscape,
we need to be able to provide
more and more emerging
technologies because of those
touch points that we have with
our guests.
We look after the digital front
doors and all of the social
media as well.
So with that, we need to
be hooked into the Cloud.
And we've been leveraging the
cloud for sometime and cloud
technologies for sometime, but
now we've partnered with Google
on some neat projects and it's
really helped us get to where we
need to go which was not
worrying so much about what's
under the hood and having our
folks focus on the product
themselves and really
the guest experience.
>> And so obviously we
thank you for picking GCP.
So what's that experience been
like working with the Cloud
team?
>> Well, it's been great.
I mean, the first thing
you do, as you guys know,
you take a very
scientific approach to it.
You send in your most cynical
software developer to go in and
meet with the Google
folks at the Googleplex.
And I'm sure you guys can close
your eyes and picture that
person in your head.
We have them too.
And so, go in there -- and
really what we were looking for
was culture.
You know, it's
trendy to say, well,
let's fail fast and
be able to experiment,
but we truly believe in that.
John Lassiter at Pixar says, "be
wrong quick."
And so we really want to take that approach to that.
We saw that with the Google team
that we could get up and running
very quickly.
The second thing we
looked at was code wins.
And so for us, that is a mantra
through all of our developers
when we say code wins and that
means can we get up in your
environment?
Can we get going?
And I've spent my whole career
in Silicon Valley and a lot of
the folks that, you know, work
at Disney you had a little peek
behind the curtain of the folks
that provide the technology for
that.
Have spent a lot of years in
high-tech companies and they
didn't come to Disney
to build a data base.
And so really what we wanted to
get out of is the conversations
of plumbing and conversations
of how do you spin things up and
more into how do we create these
really great product experiences
for our guests.
>> So like in our past
conversations that was stunning,
I don't know if
the number was 700.
The number of projects
on App Engine was huge.
But what are some of the ones
that you're thinking about that
actually you're most involved
with and getting excited?
>> Yeah, so currently, we have
over 200 projects spun up.
A lot of them are
coming out soon,
we're super excited about that.
We're going to hold that back
for larger releases with that.
But we're excited about that.
We do have a product that I'm
super excited about that we
launched called Disney life.
It was in the UK.
It's an over the top service
that not only does videos and
movies and television, but
also books and music and games.
And so that's been huge.
And the partnership with
Google has been very helpful.
In fact they even participated
in our war room to launch that
out.
So not just to be able to have
the ability to partner with
someone but not think about the
scale and knowing that they're
going to be there with you
to do that has really been
instrumental to us.
>> Awesome, well,
thanks for coming.
>> Yeah, thanks for having me.
[ Applause ]
>> So Mike and Disney aren't
that unique in that, you know,
they want to go faster.
And we've been working harder
to make all developers on APP
Engine to be able to
be more productive.
And one of the things that held
us back is to be honest was the
run times and the language
support that we could bring to
APP Engine.
And so just the way we talked
about like doctorate containers
moving the industry forward,
we've integrated containers now
with APP Engine.
And what's that's meant is that
we can now bring out new run
times in that zero ops
environment of App Engine much
quicker, so we can bring out the
latest version of java, node,
and Python.
So here's -- Greg's back and
he's going to show us a demo on
what's happening
with APP Engine.
>> Greg: Thanks, Brian.
So next up, we're going to give
you -- for the developers in the
audience a lap around
Google Cloud Platform.
And along the way I'm going to
show you a few of my favorite
developer productivity features.
So the scenario we're
going to do this -- oh,
and I've got Bret here on
stage is going to help me out.
Thank you very much, Bret.
We're going to show you an
application we built at a recent
hack-a-thon within Google.
The application is called
Photo Scavenger Hunt.
It is a mobile game.
It gives you a set of four clues
for things that it wants you to
take pictures of.
You take a picture.
If it sees the object it
asked you for in the picture,
you get points.
The architecture of the
application is actually very
simple.
It is a mobile client that talks
via a rest API to a backend
hosted on App Engine.
That App Engine uses the
vision API to see what's in the
picture, and it stores the
clues in a Mongo data base.
Now App Engine has always had
support for languages like Ruby
and Python and Go.
But today we're adding support
for new languages like no JS,
and as I said, actually, Ruby.
So in this case, we've already
got the application a little bit
of code.
So why don't, Bret,
open up the text editor.
So we're going to highlight just
a couple of lines of code here.
The first is, there we go,
the call to the Vision API.
You'll see that referenced down,
one line down to the Vision API.
And we're using two
features of the Vision API.
We're using label detection to
tell us what's in the picture,
and since I don't trust
my users entirely,
we're using safe search
protection to make sure there's
no naughty bits coming
up into our application.
We're going to run this locally.
Like many of you, our developers
sometimes want to just work
locally on their laptop.
Maybe they're on a
plane, don't have access.
So Bret's going to fire
up a local copy of Node.
And we've got this little
service running locally now.
Now I got this
picture of a raccoon.
So he's going to use Curl
to just test out the local
application and see what
he gets back as a response.
And sure enough, 95.7%
confidence in an animal and all
the way down to it
is a Procyonidae,
which I had to look that up.
And that is the family that
raccoon belongs to in a -- so I
actually learned something about
biology from our demo today.
Okay, so we got a local
version of the application.
Now let's deploy it
up into the cloud.
Now this is where normally you
get into the world of having to
configure machines,
memory, load balancers,
what operating
system should I use?
Is my image fully patched?
Not with App Engine.
I just let me just
deploy the code.
So he's going to do
a G-cloud deploy.
Now what's happening behind
the scenes here is kind of
interesting.
That source code is being
deployed up into App Engine
where it's getting ready
to be -- to be run.
That's kind of
standard App Engine.
But what's really interesting
here is for new languages like
Node, Ruby, and Java 8, it's
being packaged up as a container
and then it's being stored
in a private Google container
registry for you.
So that means I was able
to build a container-based
application without even having
Docker installed on my local
system.
Not only that, because it's
a containerized application,
it can run anywhere in
the container ecosystem.
Whatever provider you want
on Prim or in a cloud.
And, of course, it can be
orchestrated by Kubernetes just
as well.
So if you step back, what
that means is that App Engine
developers can now be a full
participant in the exciting
developments happening around
containers and container
management.
So let's actually switch
over to the console,
to the cloud console.
And let's take a look and
find that image that just got
uploaded into GCS.
So Bret's going to navigate
it over to GCS storage,
and I don't have permissions
to see the storage section.
That's not an error.
We've used identity and access
management because I'm just a
developer.
I shouldn't have access to my
customer's personal images,
right?
So we're using ACLs and identity
and access management so that I
don't have access.
Now it turns out we have the
manager logged in on a different
tab.
And here as the manager, Bret
can go in and expand out the
privileges for App Engine admin
and he could add me as a storage
admin for all of those -
all of those capabilities.
Now as the manager, maybe
I'm actually really paranoid.
It's not paranoid, it's called
actually just being a good
manager of security.
And what I want to do is see
everything that's ever been
changed about this project.
The activity stream, new
today, gives me just that.
I can see every configuration,
every policy change,
every code push, every
deployment that happens to my
application.
This is really handy for
tracking down compliance
concerns or issues and it's
really important for managers
and organizations.
Now while we're here, I want to
hit you -- I want to show you
two productivity features that
can save you a lot of time.
First, SSH from the browser.
How many of you have ever had
to SSH into a VM and you have to
deal with the hassle
of picking a password,
recording what the password
is, configuring keys.
Not with Google Cloud.
You can just -- Bret can just
one click on the right side on
any VM and immediately have
a secure SSH session to that
machine without having
to configure anything.
One click secure access.
The other time saver
is the Cloud Shell.
Have you ever found yourself
needing to do a quick bit of
work but you don't have your
laptop handy or you don't have a
machine with an SDK installed?
Cloud Shell gives you as a
developer a private persistent
LINUX instance that's
preinstalled in Google Cloud
with the latest
version of the SDK.
It's like a GCP command line
in the cloud you can access
anywhere that you are.
All you need is a
machine with browser.
The last thing I want
to show --
[ Applause ]
Yes, I knew the developers
would like that.
Another hard part about building
distributed application is
performance tracking.
Performance debugging when we
used to run on one machine was
actually pretty simple.
Now individual traces are
routed to different machines.
And how do you actually get a
consistent view of how long a
request took?
Stack Driver Trace is a
distributed tracing utility that
lets you track down exactly
where your server time is being
spent.
It gives you visualizations
like this where you can compare
latency across versions
of your application.
So you can see if your new
version is five times slower
than your old version.
Not only that, you can go down
down at the bottom and Bret will
click on an individual trace
and you can see for a given user
request exactly how long every
call took to service that
request.
So he picked a trace here and we
see there's a call to the Vision
API and the Storage API.
Individual traces down to the
individual application level.
Okay, let's actually see
this application in action.
It's been deployed,
and it's all set go.
So at this point, Bret needs
to fire up the application.
And let's take a look at --
it's asking him for a person,
a hotel, a bank note, or sports.
Bret, this is your moment.
Take a selfy on stage.
All right, let's see what
happens with the Vision API.
Checking?
Person, 92% likelihood.
[ Laughter ]
Thanks, Bret, that was great.
That was a great demo.
So, yes, please, thank Bret.
[ Applause ]
So, if you look at
those two demos,
what you're seeing is we're
trying to take you from a world
where your developers spend
their time mucking about with
infrastructure and we're opting
into paths means opting into a
walled garden of limited choices
to a world where your developers
can just write code and your
paths participants can be
connected to the whole
world of containers.
Thanks very much.
I'll bring Brian back up now.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thanks, Greg.
So some companies were born in
the Cloud and that's the only
world that they know.
But then other companies,
right, don't have that luxury.
They're traditional
companies right,
that are moving to Cloud really
rapidly and in so doing that are
actually becoming
digital businesses.
But in either case, the most
successful companies are the
ones that are actually skilled
in managing data scale.
And GCP excels at storage and
archival but it's a lot more
than that.
It's really about pulling
insights from data.
And that's what separates good
companies from great companies.
Because great companies know how
to look at data and understand
their markets,
understand their users,
how people are using
their products;
and they respond to
that really rapidly.
So managing data scale is
obviously one of the things that
makes Google Google.
We built Data,
Search, Analytics,
and that's what powered seven
applications of a billion users
each.
And we've actually been pretty
open on it publishing research
papers on most of the
technologies that you see.
And in the case of MapReduce
and BigTable and Dremel,
just those research papers have
spawned whole industries because
they've been implemented
in open source.
So as a result, when people
think about big data,
what do they think of first?
They typically think of
open source solutions.
And so now with the cloud,
our strategy is a little bit
different.
We're going to actually expose
all of those internal data
systems as first class cloud
services and that's what
actually allowed us, right, that
prior work to create an industry
first around on-line storage at
the durability and the price of
archival.
That's what's allowed us to
bring out a full manage to-do
platform but beyond that the
work that we have done inside
because the new projects we
use are typically using data
streaming pipelines, we brought
out data flow to integrate well
with a dupe as a
fully managed service.
And now with BigQuery, even
non-Googlers can process,
you know, trillion
row tables in seconds.
But as we do this, being
open isn't optional.
We really believe that
businesses are going to choose
open as the next
platform, right?
This is not a point
products decision.
This is about choosing
your platform.
So we look for every way that we
can actually be even more open
than we already are.
And a big part of that is why
when we put H-space or BigTable
on Cloud, we didn't
use our internal API.
We adopted the open
source H-space API.
And the same thing
with data flow.
I mean data flow is really
compelling and we could have
used that to our
proprietary advantage.
Instead we said let's just
open source the whole model for
configuring and
executing these runners,
these data stream pipelines
and creating Apache Incubator
Project.
So one part of the job that I
think is most fun besides like
standing here, is actually
working with customers.
Right?
And really working
with customers,
not just from a
support perspective,
but on an
engineering-on-engineering
relationship.
I mean, so 18 months ago, we
actually embarked working with a
new customer.
And it meant a lot of travel
to New York and to Sweden,
and for them to Mountain View.
We built a really great
relationship with Spotify.
>> The mission of Spotify is
really about being a great
musical companion and
making it more personal.
It's not going to be this
streaming music experience or
the online music experience,
it's going to be your music
experience.
>> We created the tools for
people to actually swim in that
sea of music data and find
the information that really
corresponds to why
they are there.
>> Quite a while ago, we made
a decision to focus on data.
>> Depending on the
complexity of the query,
it could take a whole day.
Sometimes it would
have to run overnight.
>> And being able to store that
and process that has been a very
big challenge.
Moving to Google's Cloud
Platform enabled us to take use
of the skill that
Google can provide.
>> The reality is it's quite
hard to build great data centers
and we saw an opportunity to
spend our focus elsewhere.
And that was really the driver
into Google's Cloud Platform.
>> With Google Cloud tools, we
could re-run the same query and
it might take a few
seconds, minutes.
>> The less time that we can
spend solving problems that are
already solved, like scaling our
Hadoop cluster when Google has
already figured out how to
scale it for us,
the more time and energy we can
spend on turning our data into
value.
And that's really a
game changer for us.
When you're talking about a
technology like BigQuery and
when you're talking
about data flow,
you will feel the Spotify
product evolve making the user
experience great.
>> Once you break down the
data, you realize that there are
nuances, it's not a
straightforward path.
It's a mosaic rich beyond
the most popular artist.
It's a lot more than that.
>> Music can transcend
boundaries of language, culture.
If it moves you then it's
there and it's there forever.
>> So please --
[ Applause ]
So please welcome Nick Harteau.
The VP of Infrastructure
at Spotify.
[ Music ]
>> How's it going?
>> Hey, Nick.
Good.
>> Actually, before we get started with the questions,
can we do another round of
applause for Brian and Greg and
the engineers who helped out
for the amazing live demos?
[ Applause ]
I know that it's not jumping out of airplanes with the VR goggles on.
>> It's not in the script.
>> No, it's not in the script.
It's not jumping out of
airplanes with VR goggles on,
but for me as an engineer,
that was real bravery,
the live demo stuff.
>> Well, thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> So, really, it's been
great working with Spotify.
We've helped you but I have to
say that you've made us better
as well.
Today we actually handed you a
new piece of code for connecting
projects securely without
having public IPs,
so just another set of firsts
between the two companies so
thank you, for working
with us closely.
So, why did you decide to move
some of your platform to Google
Cloud Platform?
>> Well, I mean, going
back to your presentation,
I think the thing that drew
us to Google over other cloud
providers actually
was the data platform.
At Spotify, we are -- whether
it's like A/V testing product
changes or building personalized
play lists for millions of users
every week, we are deeply
dependent on data to understand
our users and to bring
them great user experience.
And Google, as we
saw on your timeline,
you guys have been a thought
leader in the data space for as
far back as I can remember.
And I think you've done a great
job of bringing that leadership
and that expertise to GCP in
the form of like great tools and
services.
So the data platform more than
anything else was the game
changer for us.
>> So we know some of the engine
is already moved on top of the
cloud.
So just like how's
the migration going?
Any challenges you've
had along the way?
>> Yeah, I mean we have a pretty
big and complicated backend.
I think we have 250 or so
services that power Spotify.
So there's not a simple
answer to that question.
You know, some of
it is pretty easy,
other stuff is pretty hard.
But you know, overall, I would
say it's going better than we
expected.
We have our set of challenges.
You know we're figuring out
some stuff related to time
syncrhonization.
We are -- we're learning a bunch
of new API semantics in adopting
the platform.
But overall, it's
going pretty well.
Besides the usual
stuff about, you know,
changing the tires on the car
while we're driving down the
highway.
>> Easy stuff.
>> Yeah.
>> So we loved the tweets.
So we -- definitely that person is a --
>> I think he's pretty happy about not having --
>> He's inaugarated into our marketing hall of fame.
So we thank him for that.
So what else are you sort
of hearing from just the
experience?
What services are kind of
the most delightful for your
engineers?
>> Well, there's two things
I'd want to call out on the
migration before we go into
the services side of it.
I would say one thing is -- one
thing that we're like really
concerned about and
really, you know,
at the top of our minds in terms
of moving to the cloud has been
performance.
We're a super latency
sensitive application.
We rely very much on our users
feeling like they have the
world's music like right
there on their phones.
So we've been really watching
the metrics very carefully as
we've been moving
into the cloud.
And we've been really
happy with that.
The numbers that we're seeing in
terms of performance are as good
as what we can deliver
from our own data centers.
>> Cool.
>> The other thing to pat
you on the back a little bit.
One of the big unknowns for
us going into the Google
partnership actually was
the customer service side.
Like as I said, it's a big and
complicated migration and I knew
that we would need to rely a lot
on support from Google in order
to do it well.
We've really been
blown away there.
So thank you for the great
partnership and the great
support.
>> Awesome, great, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> One of
Spotify's challenges was,
can you imagine, is that as big
as that service is is just the
pure ingestion rate
that they have.
And moving from Kafka and
taking advantage of PubSub?
So the ingestion
rate is amazing.
Running services at
that scale is amazing.
So we actually wanted to give
you a demo and show you a
version of these
services in action.
>> Okay, one last time with me.
So, I think Nick mentioned this.
But at its peak, Spotify is
serving something like a billion
streams.
I need a slide update here.
I've got Eric Schmitt on stage
to help me with this demo.
Not the Eric Schmitt
from earlier,
but a slightly
different Eric Schmitt.
You can imagine the fun
crossings of e-mail that they
have.
Yeah, exactly.
The first step we want to --
we want to start with here is
ingestion.
One of the challenges that
Spotify has is how to take data
and bring it in at the kind
of rates that they deal with.
They use Cloud PubSub
in order to do that.
Cloud PubSub is a fully managed
service for ingesting data at
scale.
Now what we're going to show you
here is the same sort of tools
and give you a glimpse of how
Spotify analyzes their data.
Now, Spotify actually treats
their customer data and privacy
very, very securely.
So we have generated some test
data of the same volume and the
same shape that Spotify
actually encounters.
So what you see here may not
exactly match what Spotify sees
in production.
So let's start with ingestion.
This pipeline is currently
running at about 150,000
to 200,000 events per second.
Now this actually
is running now.
And throughout the demo,
while we do this demo,
we're going to continuously be
ingesting more user events at
about 100,000, 200,000
events per second.
They can get up to 700,000.
And what these events are are
all of the interactions that
people do with their mobile
application on Spotify.
You hit play, you pause,
you skip, you share,
you make a play list.
That data is gold for Spotify
in terms of building a better
service or building new
features like discovery weekly.
And with PubSub, they can
ingest that data at scale,
at volume without having
to manage infrastructure.
Without having to maintain
their own Kafka clusters.
So PubSub is globally
available, fully managed.
It scales from a few events
per section up to hundreds of
thousands.
Now the next step after the
data has been ingested is you
actually need to extract that
data and transform it into the
various storage systems.
So Eric's going to switch over
and we're going to show data
flow.
Spotify is actively working on
moving to data flow as their
centralized ETO
processing system.
This is a data
flow visualization,
and it's running
live as we talk now.
And it's taking
data, sharding it,
windowing it by hour so that
they get hour-by-hour updates to
the data and then ultimately
writing that data into multiple
data sources, BigQuery, GCS, HTFS.
And it does all this with
a fraction of the latency.
What used to take an hour
now takes 15 minutes.
So they're able to get much
closer to realtime access to how
users are interacting
with their application.
So that's our pipeline
running, and, again,
this is running live
while we're on stage.
We can ingest the data,
we can run a pipeline,
we can store it in
the different systems.
Now we actually want to find
the needles in the haystack.
We want to analyze.
And that's where
BigQuery comes in.
Eric's written a query here that
is going to calculate the top
artists that people
are streaming.
Now, bear in mind, this is test
data so it may not match what
billboard says the
actual top artists are.
So he's going to go
ahead and run this query.
And while it runs, let me tell
you that this query is going to
join over a billion events of
user interaction with over 20
million tracks of music
with over a million artists.
And in four seconds, it
processes 22 gigs of data to
come up with that -- Justin
Bieber is the top artist.
Well, the demo is Bieberlicious
so far, let's plow on.
But again, what's valuable
here is what you're not seeing.
There's no recreating indexes
when the data goes up by a
factor of ten.
There's no maintaining VMs,
there's no patching operating
systems.
They just get to write queries
and get data on the other side.
Great, so now we've
looked at the data.
Let's take a look at how
Spotify might be able to do
collaborative analysis with a
product like Cloud Data Lab.
Cloud Data Lab gives you
these nice visual notebooks.
It's based on Jupiter, the open
source project formerly known as
iPython.
And it allows you to combine not
just BigQuery data but because
it's based on Python, you
actually can use really popular
packages like Pandas
to do analytics.
So at the top, you see that
-- let's just scroll back --
there's that same BigQuery
query that we just used in the
console.
But if you go down
to the bottom,
we're piping that into a Pandas
data frame in order to be able
to do visualizations and
charts right within Pandas.
So we made a data
frame out of it.
We asked Pandas to plot it.
And you see we've got a
pretty typical fat head,
long tail distribution of music.
And that got Eric
and I thinking.
You know, maybe there's another
more valuable way to look at
this than just top plays.
Maybe we should do further
analysis and take into account
the number of tracks
that you have,
not just the number of plays.
Data Lab allows me to do this
sort of interactive what-if
analysis in a visual notebook
way that could be shared with
other users.
So we've added more on -- we've
extended this BigQuery to
calculate what we call how
interesting an artist is by
taking into account how
many tracks there are.
So he's going to run the rest
of our analysis through to
completion.
And this query -- this
analysis will be running live.
Again, data is being streamed,
data flow is continuing to pump
that data in.
We're getting realtime looks.
And by this, it looks like
Nirvana and Torii Amos and Bob
Dylan are more interesting than
Justin Bieber so all is right
with the world.
[ Applause ]
So, one last thing.
What about summarizing the data
and building dashboards for your
managers to get realtime
live information?
Data Studio 360 is a new service
that allows you to do just that.
To create beautiful
dashboard visualizations.
And it works not only with Google Cloud Services like
BigQuery, but it also works with
Google Analytics so you can
combine your business data
with your web traffic data.
And it works with Google Sheets
so if you have spreadsheets with
ad hoc data, all of that can
be brought into Data Studio.
So here's our version
of the dashboard here.
And you'll notice it's showing
you the number of events,
the number of unique users,
the number of unique tracks.
We've got some very nice
visualizations of charts about
where -- whether somebody
is searching or browsing.
So, we're going to extend this
-- this dashboard and get some
access to geographic
information.
Because one of the things we
know about users is when they
registered, what city
did they register.
So Eric is going to drop a map
control onto our dashboard.
Great.
And he's going to connect
that map up to two pieces of
information.
He's going to tell it --
he's going to tell it --
proof that
these are live demos.
Okay, got an issue.
What you would have seen is he
would connect that data up to
our user information, be able
to identify the city and state.
Oh, there it goes.
See, I just needed
to be patient.
Connect it up to the user.
He's going to tell it that
the information that we're
interested in looking at is the
city that the user is registered
in and that the data we want
is the number of streams that
they've listened to.
And then as he does this, you'll
see the data start to propagate
in in real time with a map.
So it automatically showed
me a map of the U.S.
The circles start to bubble in.
He can drill down and say yeah,
I really care about California.
And, again, he didn't have
to build that, all built in.
So there you have, ingestion,
processing, analysis,
a map dashboarding.
[ Applause ]
>> Thanks, Eric.
That was a great demo.
So, again, we're trying to take
you from a world where your data
scientists have to babysit
infrastructure and spend 80% of
their time on that instead of on
insights to a world where your
data people can just
get the insights.
Thanks very much.
I'll turn it back over to Brian.
>> So, pretty exciting.
For the past few years we've
been working on sort of what's
next.
Right?
And for us that was, can you
actually start with raw data and
get insights out of raw data?
So can you look at just pixels
and understand what the object
is?
Can you look inside -- teach a
computer to actually listen to
just sounds, raw sounds, and
understand what the spoken word
is?
Or can you have a computer study
the game of Go and actally be
able to beat the world champion?
So two or three years ago, the
answer to all three of those
would have been no.
Right?
But now we can actually say yes.
So at Google, we've been rapidly
building machine learning into
all of our products.
Right?
And that's why Android Voice
Recognition has gotten so good.
That's why Google Translate can
translate over 100 languages.
And that's why, you know, you're
actually seeing what we're doing
with Google Photos where you can
recognize now it's upwards of
tens of thousands of objects.
So on GCP, we're going to give
you that very same machine
learning technology so
that you can use it, right?
So whether you want to use
the entire solutions around
vision-speech translate.
Or whether you actually want
to train your own models using
Tensor Flow.
So one of the very
same Googlers, right,
that started this whole dupe
craze by becoming one of the
first authors to map reduce is
actually leading our machine
learning efforts.
So my pleasure to welcome Jeff
Dean, the lead of Googlebrain.
[ Applause ]
>> All right, thanks, Brian.
So I think machine learning
is actually one of the most
important things that's
happening in computing.
I think it's comparable in
importance to the rise of the
personal computer, with the
internet, or cloud computing,
or mobile devices.
It's really going to transform
not just computer science,
but lots and lots
of other industries.
And for us at Google, we've been
using deep learning for the last
several years.
And it's really kind of the
secret sauce we've been putting
behind more and more products.
You can see kind of our
trajectory of incorporating it
into more and more
different kinds of areas.
And the breadth of different
areas that this kind of
technology is applicable to is
pretty surprising and startling.
And when we started out in 2012
using deep learning in some of
our products, it was complicated
and kind of difficult.
And we built some infrastructure
systems to make it a bit eaiser.
We're now on our second
generation system and we've made
it a lot easier.
And that's why you see that
rise in the different teams,
that have been able to apply
this to their products.
So one of the things that can
make it easy is perhaps you want
to use pretrained models that
just work for a variety of
different kinds of domains and
you want to be able to use them
through very simple APIs.
So we've had the cloud translate
API for quite a while now.
It allows you to basically give
text in one language and we give
you back corresponding
text in another language.
We think it's the best
translate service in the world.
It's very simple to use.
And people have liked
that for quite a while.
More recently, we introduced
the Cloud Vision API, which is,
again, a very simple API to use.
You give an image, we give you
back all kinds of good stuff.
So, you know, this is the kind
of information we can give you
from the raw pixels of an image.
So let me give you a demo just
over the kinds of stuff you can
get from Cloud Vision.
So if we go here -- it would
be more helpful if my demo was
up.
Let's see.
Uh-oh.
There we go, sorry.
What we've done here is
we've taken about 100,000
images and run them all
through the Cloud Vision API.
And so each vertex in this
cluster graph is essentially one
image.
And if I zoom in here, you
know, you see images flying by.
Let's just kind of
pick one of them.
I have a precanned
one, because he's cute.
A little doggy.
So if you run this
image through,
this is the kind of data that
you can get from the Cloud
Vision API.
So let's just walk through a few
of the different kinds of data
you might be able to
extract for images.
We have another cute
animal, that's the internet.
So we have a cat.
We tell you it's a cat.
But more importantly, we tell
you it's a British short hair
and maybe a semilong hair.
So we can give you pretty fine
grain information about what --
about what this kind
of image contains.
Another thing that's pretty
useful for images is, you know,
the visual world often
has lots of text in it.
And traditionally, it's been a
big barrier to using text that
you see in images because you
can't actually extract it very
well.
But the Vision API can actually
just give you the ASCII text we
find in the image.
And, you know, when you make the
call, you'll get back, you know,
a very structured kind of thing
here where we tell you the
labels and there's the actual
text for the thing as an ASCII
string and you can do
whatever you want with that.
Faces are another kind of
important thing for photographs
that people take.
So it's actually pretty nice
that we can identify where faces
are in the images.
We can tell you if a particular
face is happy or sad.
You know, some of the
people here are happy.
Not everyone.
And again, that comes back as
like pretty structured j-sign
information.
Another kind of important thing
is people often take photographs
of sort of popular
landmarks around the world.
And so, you knowm, here's
a picture of a stadium,
we'd like to know where that is
so we can click on the landmark
detection facility and that
tells us it's Citi Field,
Stadium, gives us the
longitude, latitude.
That turns out to be in New York
because that's where the Mets
play.
And finally, sometimes it's
useful to be able to look at a
logo or an image and understand
what logos appear in it.
And so we can tell you that that
image is the Android 2.2 logo.
Great.
Okay.
So that's kind of a tour of the
kinds of things you can do with
the Vision API.
If you have lots of visual
imagery, you can run it through,
you know, Vision API,
cluster it, manipulate it,
extract information from it.
And we think that's a really
powerful kind of concept for a
lot of kinds of things
you might want to do.
We're not going to
stop at vision, though.
We've had a really good speech
recognition system for quite a
while on our android phones and
we're now exposing this as an
additional API.
It's again very simple to use.
You essentially just give us an
audio wav form and we give you
back a transcript of
what is being said.
And it works in, you know,
dozens of different languages,
actually more than 50 languages,
and it basically allows you to
convert audio to text using
machine learning under the
covers.
One of the really nice things
is it can work in both a batch
mode, if you just have a lot
of text or audio that's already
been recorded, but it could
also work in a streaming mode.
And so someone could be
speaking into a phone,
you send that to the cloud and
we give you back a transcript in
real time.
So we think that's
pretty powerful.
So those pretrain models are a
really good way to get started
using the power of machine
learning and building insights
into the data you
might already have.
Let me show you now,
to switch gears a bit,
let's talk about how you might
want to sort of design and train
your own machine learn models.
So we've been doing this over
the last five or six years.
Now, TensorFlow is a system that
we open sourced in November of
last year.
It's already the number one
repository for GitHub for
machine learning in five months.
So we're pretty happy with that.
The external community has
been very receptive to this.
You know, I think one of the
nice things about TensorFlow's
release was we put together a
bunch of tutorials that come
with it that show you how to do
different kinds of machine learning tasks.
And that's been pretty
well receive I think.
So we originally designed it
as a system and platform to be
flexible enough for trying lots
of different kinds of machine
learning ideas and research.
But also then be robust enough
to take it and then scale those
ideas to real world data set
sizes and then move them to
deployment in real products
in the same system.
So we want really easy and
flexible ways of expressing
machine learning models and then
move them to production really
easily.
So, the outside reception to the
TensorFlow open source project
has been really great.
There's already 800 repositories
on get help alone that use
TensorFlow in some way.
I'll just show you one example.
So there's a really cool paper
from a couple of universities in
Germany where you can give an
image and a painting and then it
will render that image in
the style of that painter.
So this is Van
Gogh's Starry Night.
Plus that image of
the Boston skyline,
and it's rendered in the style
of Van Gogh but it's the Boston
skyline, which presumably
Van Gogh didn't get to see.
And that's all
expressed in TensorFlow.
There's an easy repository that
you can download it and use.
So the power of TensorFlow is
that people can use it to do all
kinds of different things
and people already are.
So one of the things that
we found is that it's really
important to bring the power of
machine learning to all kinds of
different users both
internally and now externally.
So I'm really happy to announce that we're introducing a
cloud machine learning product
based around TensorFlow.
So really this product will
allow you to understand your
data, visualize it, prepare
it for machine learning,
using the other tools that
already exist in our cloud,
and then you can use the power
of our system to solve your
problems and your particular
contacts or problems.
So, and then we allow you to
take those models that you've
developed and deploy
them at scale.
So enough talking about that.
Let's actually see how this
might work in practice with a
demo.
So if we go back over here.
What I have here is, again,
another Data Lab Notebook.
So the Data Lab Notebook
style is a really easy way to
collaborate on having multiple
people work on trying to figure
out a good machine learning
model for a particular problem
you might have.
What we've done here is put in
this notebook we have downloaded
some data from our Criteo
Kaggle competition.
So this is just a data set
of 10 gigabites in size.
45 million records.
These are a few of
the records there.
And what you see is it has a
bunch of integer fields plus
some string fields.
These are actually hashed
for anonymization for the
competition.
But these might be things like
the city the user was in or
something.
And then we're going to try
to predict whether or not this
particular set of other
variables resulted in a click or
not.
So our goal was to take all of
the other data in the record and
predict is this a click or not?
And you can imagine, you know,
that kind of scenario is pretty
common in a lot of settings
where you might have customers
and you want to predict if
they're going to buy something
this month or you might have
patients and predict if they
might want follow-up
visits or something.
So, one of the things in Data
Lab is that it allows you to
really easily get a sense of
the kind of data that exists.
You know, you can get histograms
for each of the fields in your
data set.
You can understand which ones
might have missing values and so
on.
But integrated into this, we
sat down -- and a few machine
learning colleagues and I sat
down on a whiteboard and we
designed a model that we want to
try for this particular problem.
So in this particular case,
we're going to use enrollment,
because those work pretty
well for a lot of problems.
And we're going to take
the string data here,
put it through an embedding,
take the numeric data,
the integer of that field,
concatenate all of that data
together as a set of features
and then put a single layer
neural network followed by a
single logistic unit at the top
to predict yes or no for click.
So that's our training label.
And then we're going to have an
optimizer that's going to try to
optimize this path.
So that's kind of what we came
up with at the white board.
This, I won't delve in too much,
but this is kind of the code you
would write in a TensorFlow
to express such a model.
So, essentially,
you have a graph.
We're going to have some routine
in this little bit of code that
creates input to read the
records from the training data
set.
We're going to create those
hidden layers I talked about
with the rectified linear units
and then we're going to create
our final logistic unit and
then create a training procedure
that's going to optimize the
loss of that logistic unit.
So this is like one of those
routines, create a hidden layer.
So you get the raw sense.
You know, it's not
two lines of code,
but it's not so complicated.
So one of the great things about
this being TensorFlow is that
you can actually run this
locally on your laptop.
So many of you
probably flew here,
and you might not have internet
access on the plane home.
So you can actually just run
your TensorFlow model locally.
So you can -- that's the
command you would run.
And then after a little while,
we will have a trained model.
And this is a graph
of training over time.
So this is the number of
seconds that our model has been
training.
The blue line is our loss
on the training data set.
And the yellow line is the
error on the validation side.
And we want the
error to go down.
And sure enough at the beginning
of training, it was not so good,
and then it's gradually
been creeping down.
And obviously being able to
predict this metric better could
be quite important in the
particular application you might
have in mind.
So that's great.
And after about 30,000 seconds,
we got down to an error of .304.
So, great.
So let me show you how you
make this use our cloud machine
learning product.
You take that command line
before and you add dash,
dash cloud.
And you can also
optionally tell us hey,
how many replicas do you
want to use for this model.
So in this case, we want to use
20 replicas so we're going to
get 20 way parallelism in
optimizing this particular
model.
And now, we get pretty much
the same looking curve,
which is good.
And it goes down to about, what is that, .306, 304 at the end.
I'll show you a
comparative graph.
But it did it in about .19 seconds.
So that's the difference between
kind of a full day before you
kind of get the answer to your
experiment versus, you know,
20 minutes, 30
minutes, you know,
you go get a cup of coffee, come
back, and now you can iterate.
The same way the Spotify team
was talking about how they get
much faster itteration and are
able to sort of explore their
data and make insights
much more quickly,
this is the same kind of
thing for machine learning.
And here you can see graphs
of the local processing and
instances per second.
A 10 replica version in yellow
and a 20 replica version in
green.
And just to kind of show you,
this is the magnitude that you
get in improvement of error
over time if you use the single
replica versus the 10
replica and the 20 replica.
And if I switch this to stats
which is a kind of update to the
model, you see they're
almost on top of each other.
It just happens
20 times as fast.
So that's great.
So we now have a trained model.
What do we want to do with it?
Well, one thing we might want to
do is actually deploy that to a
production setting and see
do we actually observe real
improvements.
So what I have here is an
open source load testing tool,
and it's pointed at making
requests to get predictions to
one of the models
that we trained.
And you see we're getting about
-- we're simulating 100 users
kind of concurrently using some
service and we're doing about 12
requests per second.
So one of the real nice things
is to go from, you know,
the idea you had to a deployed
model and then if it's
successful, to not have to
worry about scaling anything.
You don't want to have
any sort of you know,
ops required to add capacity.
So let's simulate 100
times as many users now.
And i'm just going to hit
reload on the refresh tool.
And all of a sudden,
we're hatching new users,
apparently they're --
they need hatching.
So what you see is the latency
is hovering pretty steadily.
Requests per second are ramping
up, and all of a sudden,
you know, in maybe 10
or 15 more seconds,
we're going to go from low-X to
100-x without any work on our
part required.
And that's kind of the
experience that we think you
need for getting machine
learning and trying out lots of
ideas, iterating
quickly on the ideas,
and then taking that idea and
moving it into a production
setting without
any muss or fuss.
So that's what we have there.
[ Applause ]
Yeah.
So we think that's going to
be pretty exciting for lots of
people.
And we need kind of early
users of this system to give us
feedback so we can get it to
be really robust and solid,
and even easier to use when
we go to general availability.
But it's in alpha as of today.
So we have ready to use machine
learn models, translate, vision,
and the cloud speech ATI.
This is an area we'll
be building out more of.
We think there's a lot more that
can be done in this particular
area.
And then what I showed you today
is our cloud machine learning
product, which works in
collaboration with all of our
other products where you're
already storing your data in our
cloud.
You want to start doing some
data lab exploration and then
you want to train
machine learning models.
And using TensorFlow, you're not
locked into our cloud platform.
You can take that same model,
run it on your desktop or on
your own premises, deploy
it on your own premises,
deploy it in our cloud,
it's very flexible,
and allows you to really move
however -- decide how you want
to use this thing
in your business.
So we're really
excited about this.
So now the kind of tools we
give you are really the kinds of
things that allow you to do
basic things like store and
analyze the data.
These kinds of tools are really
going to be allowing you to get
an understanding of your data
and really give you the insights
you need to build the
products you want.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> And I'll welcome back Brian.
>> Thanks, Jeff.
So first now we can say all
of those demos were live.
I didn't want to say that early
because you know what happens if
you tell you are
showing live demos.
And that was because, you know,
the engineers and the product
managers, they work
for months on these.
And they really want you to see
the technology and not just a
lot of presentations.
So thanks to all of the teams.
[ Applause ]
So, as you can see,
Google Cloud Platform isn't this
single service.
In our opinion, it's a
collection of beautiful and well
integrated APIs that let you
do the traditional things like
spinning up the VM and give
me the OS that I care about,
or they're really
advanced things.
Give me a zero-ops auto scaler
and spread my data across five
regions.
But it's also the place where
security and operational control
come together so that the most
risk-averse of enterprises can
put the first application on
top of cloud or integrate our
network directly into
their own premise.
And it's also the first place
that new technology is being
born.
Things like deep learning and
put directly in the hands of
developers that never would
have been able to access that
technology in the past.
So we really want you to take
advantage of the next two days,
right.
So we have some great
sessions for you.
We've got an evening
event tonight.
Tomorrow we have -- in
the general session,
we have three talks.
You're going to hear from the
person that leads all of our
data centers,
really fascinating.
You're going to hear the person
that's going to tell you where
the TL for ware containers and
where this is all going as well
as from Niels on what's
happening inside of Google
security.
But most importantly as well,
like we've sent a lot of
engineers here that aren't
giving formal presentations.
So really take advantage of the
hallway conversations, right?
Meet the engineers
let the -- you know,
have some conversations
around that.
And there's developers from
other companies that have come
here all over the world.
So it's really all
about the conversations.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]